et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
benjamin hammam professeur d'histoire
porte parole cgt 94 bonsoir benjamin
marc à vos côtés pierre fabre vice
président du syndicat national des
écoles bonsoir à vous aussi pierre favre
donc inquiétude on l'aura compris en ce
jour de rentrée tous les voyants sont au
rouge jérôme c'est le monde le directeur
général de la santé s'alarmant de
possibles brassage de populations ont
engendré par les fêtes vous propose tout
d'abord de regarder les enfants
reviennent de différents endroits en
france ou à l'étranger
ça peut rabattre les cartes de la
situation épidémiologique 1re en cause
notamment la variante du cornât virus
qui contamine beaucoup les enfants en
angleterre et qui au coeur des
préoccupations
l'angleterre qui a bouclé en urgence
toutes les écoles de londres pour deux
semaines
la france doit-elle suivre le même
chemin par mesure de précaution la
jamaah m'a alors en l'occurrence le
chemin emprunté par l'angleterre n'est
n'est pas simplement suivi par par ce
pays il ya le la pologne à l'autriche
les pays-bas l'irlande
enfin voilà la grèce il ya toute une
série de pays qui ont décidé de reporter
de quelques jours ou de quelques
semaines la rentrée et donc il
semblerait qu'en france les maquereaux
nist qui nous donne souvent l'impression
dans notre pays d'avoir raison contre
tous les autres français ont visiblement
aussi l'impression d'avoir raison contre
le reste du monde
mais quand on quand on fait allusion à
la phrase de monsieur salomon elle
tranche quand même étrangement avec le
discours de jean michel blanquer rière
jean michel blanc guerre à dire
quasiment dans le texte la situation est
suffisamment satisfaisantes pour que la
rentrée ait lieu normalement
et quand on écoute effectivement
monsieur salomon la phrase que vous avez
vous même site et à l'instant eh bien on
ne comprend pas là encore une fois on
entend on entend des choses complètement
complètement contradictoire les motifs
pour s'inquiéter sont multiples vous
l'avez dit il y a le le retour des fêtes
il y à la baisse des températures
et puis moi il ya quelque chose que je
comprends pas juste avant les vacances
le 15 décembre
vous dit ecoutez jean michel blanquer
renaudies vous allez avoir le jeudi et
le vendredi et le samedi juste avant la
rentrée
juste avant les vacances par an vous
allez il conseillait aux familles de ne
pas mettre leurs enfants à l'école parce
que ils pourraient contaminer les
personnes âgées lors des fêtes de noël
à ce moment là on a onze mille contaminé
de plus haut le 15 novembre a annoncé la
situation aujourd'hui plus tôt hier on
nous avions dix neuf mille contaminé
supplémentaires c'est à dire on avait
quasiment le double et on nous dit mais
vous devez tout va très bien madame la
marquise circulez ya rien à voir
faye a rien qui se tient honnêtement il
n'y a rien qui se tient on va interroger
pierre fin pour avoir son avis à
l'instar de benjamin hammam nous ne
sommes pas assez prudent en france
pierre fabre vous savez c'est très
compliqué de savoir ce qu'il faut faire
les gens qui savent après coup ce qu'il
fallait faire son aux très nombreux ils
s'expriment souvent après mes rares
marins il faut juste être un peu plus
précis sur ce que disait benjamin amar
mon collègue de la cgt le 15 décembre
c'est pas jean michel blanquer dit qu'on
pouvait être tolérant sur les deux
derniers jours c'est le premier ministre
jean castex ce qui ne retient rien à la
boulette mais ça montre que jean michel
blanquer l'hommiste et pas un seul à la
manoeuvre et malheureusement le
sentiment que nous avons c'est qu'il ya
parfois un peu de fébrilité en périodes
comme celle que nous vivons
je crois qu'il faut se souvenir des
paroles de sénèque qui disait vivre ce
n'est pas à prendre à éviter l'orage
apprendre à danser sous la pluie ce qui
est ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
online pandémie on a des risques on a
des difficultés et on a des arbitrages à
faire alors nous sur le terrain on
essaie autant que possible mon collègue
benjamin le sait d'autant que moi de
veiller à respecter tous au maximum le
protocole pour que les enfants puissent
être le plus en sécurité les collègues
également mais on a aussi me semble-t-il
en tant que citoyens à comprendre que
ces arbitrages sont toujours délicats
toujours à revoir fermer les écoles
retarder la rentrée
ne nous semble pas la priorité
aujourd'hui et je crois qu'on peut
rappeler aussi que l'ensemble des
organisations syndicales
tiens à ce que les écoles restent autant
que possible ouverte dans les meilleures
conditions possibles pour maintenir le
service public d'éducation opérationnel
voilà alors c'est vrai qu'on va regarder
la situation en europe 1 dont nous
parlait d'ailleurs benjamin marc c'est
vrai qu'il n'ya plus beaucoup d'écoliers
un petit ou grand d'ailleurs qui
préparent leur cartable matin pour se
rendre
on court regarder en rouge les pays où
les écoles sont fermées en bleu les
pénibles les écoles sont encore ouvertes
il y en a cinq la france la belgique
l'espagne le portugal et la suisse
benjamin marque quand on interroge
certains pédiatres notamment le
professeur cohen que vous devez
connaître infectiologues pédiatre à
l'hôpital de créteil nous dit c'était le
bon moment quand même en france pour
ouvrir les écoles parce qu'on n'est tout
simplement pas dans la même situation
aujourd'hui qu'au royaume uni ou en
allemagne
qu'est ce que vous lui répondez d2 je
comprends pas bien moi quand on entend
encore une fois olivier ferrand ou quand
on quand on écoute le gouvernement on
comprend bien que enfin personne n'a nié
qu en france la troisième vague était en
train de de poindre son nez que l'idée à
nouveau confinement est dans toutes les
têtes
il ya aucune moi ce qui me choque c'est
qu'en réalité dans cette situation comme
beaucoup de français je vois bien que la
cohérence est aux abonnés absents et et
nous justement on est cohérent je
rebondis sur ce que disait mon
interlocuteur la cgt elle a toujours
tenu un discours qui était un discours
exigeant très exigeant sur notamment au
moment lorsqu'on mais on nous disait
qu'il fallait retourner à l'école
lorsque à la rentrée de la toussaint on
nous disait mais tout va très bien le
protocole est formidable on a toujours
été sur la question de la santé et je
moi je
je veux aussi vous voulez que va-t-il se
passer si parce que là les chiffres sont
en pleine explosion
que se passe-t-il si dans une semaine on
nous parle à nouveau un à nouveau dans
le confinement
on va encore avoir cette logique à deux
vitesses qui nous explique que le virus
qu'on les road dans un certain nombre
d'endroits mais il est absent comme par
magie et trans une distanciation dans
d'autres endroits
on a ça a souvent été évoquée encore
hier jean michel blanquer a dû répondre
à des questions là-dessus sur le fait
qu'on ferme les restaurants mais par
contre dans les cantines scolaires tout
va très bien là aussi tout va très bien
le cluster ne vient le virus ne vient
jamais prendre son plateau dans les
selfs scolaire c'est ridicule
mais encore une fois je veux dire le on
sait bien la main armée mais la caisse
pardonnez moi messieurs mais la question
j'ai envie de vous poser vous êtes
peut-être plus au courant que moi parce
que les chiffres seront les a on a quand
même un retour d'expérience désormais
avec ces écoles qui sont restées
ouvertes
est-ce qu'on a des chiffres qui parlent
tout simplement pour nous dire voilà les
écoles sont un cluster c'est dangereux
oui ou non pierre favre alors il y a eu
une polémique au moins de ventes sur les
chiffres précisément parce que les
chiffres de la rs ne correspondait pas
aux chiffres de l'éducation nationale
c'était l'occasion de pointer un petit
peu le drame de notre pays très sûr
administrés ou beaucoup d'experts
ce sont au programme experts mais ne
communique pas et donc on avait
effectivement un gros hiatus entre les
chiffres annoncés par l'éducation
nationale jean michel blanquer relire
appelé 0,3 pour cent des élèves qui
étaient qui étaient concernés ce qui
était tout à fait effectivement
rassurant est négligeable
et puis les chiffres de la rs qui
comptabilisait tous les enfants qui
s'étaient présentés pour faire des tests
alors bien entendu la vérité est quelque
part dans le fait que dans les écoles ne
sont remontés que la partie visible de l
iceberg et une quantité d'informations
ne sont pas véhiculés par les parents
qui estiment ou dont le médecin
conseille de dire dans mes côtés na li
na fallait pas tout le monde ça va bien
se passer
et donc on se retrouve avec des chiffres
qui sont effectivement au départ d'un
doute au départ d'un soupçon par rapport
à ça je crois qu'il est sain dans une
démocratie comme la france que toutes
les voies puissent s'exprimer que tous
les scientifiques puissent avoir pignon
sur rue
il faut graver faire de cette situation
où les chiffres sont sujets à discussion
de cette situation où la situation est
un petit peu délicate en faire une
occasion de sang froid de recul de
comparaison et je dirais aussi un
exercice de confiance parce qu'à un
moment donné je dirais que benjamin a
marre parce qu'il est il est professeur
d'histoire donc il est sur le terrain
vaut benjamin vous avez tout simplement
vu des collègues qui sont tombés malades
parce que contaminés à l'école où ces
sujets comme le dit pierre fabre à
caution finalement on a des doutes
alors c'est une excellente question
parce que sur le terrain moi aussi je
suis un enseignant en activité sur le
sur le terrain c'est un cirque
incroyable d'abord parce que les
enseignants n'ont pas toujours des
informations sur la situation sanitaire
de leur propre établissement
on nous a invoqué régulièrement le
secret médical ce qui est
particulièrement ridicule vu que lakovic
19 est une maladie à déclaration
obligatoire
on nous a on a aussi
il ya des trous monstrueux dans la
raquette lorsque on a découvert il ya
vait comment dire
c'était la pêche aux informations sur la
situation des cas positifs des cas
contacts etc
et c'est d'ailleurs pour cela encore une
fois que à larrau à la rentrée de la
toussaint dans bon nombre
d'établissements en france il y a eu des
mouvements de grève et de droit de
retrait parce que alors même que on
avait une recrudescence de l'épidémie un
nouveau confinement
le protocole n'était pas du tout adaptée
jean michel blanquer déjà à l'époque
nous disait tout va très bien et il a
fallu se bagarrer pendant une semaine
pour que on est enfin un protocole
renforcé donc la colère des enseignants
elle se fonde sur cette expertise de
terrain
et lorsque j'écoutais encore une fois le
ministre de l'éducation nationale hier
et bien entre ce qu'il disait et ce que
vivent les collègues sur le terrain il y
à une galaxie
je donne un autre exemple jean michel
blanc guerre disait hier m'ont écouté
l'absentéisme
justement lors des trois derniers jours
avant avant les congés était finalement
à la marge disait-il pas écoutez moi
dans mes derniers court j'avais un élève
voilà un bien faible à la dernière
question
voilà défaut de fermer les écoles est ce
qu'il faut encore un peu plus et surtout
est-ce que c'est possible renforcer ce
protocole sanitaire dont on parle
souvent
non je reprends comme mon collègue
benjamin a marre l'exemple vécu puisque
comme lui je suis sur le terrain je suis
directeur d'une école
je peux vous dire que j'ai eu zéro
absents castex moi j'ai zappé les
absents castex les deux derniers jours
fermer les écoles c'est un choix
politique majeur qui a des conséquences
majeures qui ne doit être pris vraiment
dans des conditions qui sont terribles
il faut effectivement regarder une
évolution de la pandémie les givrés leur
manière que vous montriez est très bien
faite puisqu'on voit bien à droite tous
les pays qu'ils ferment qui sont dans la
façade est du pays et la péninsule
ibérique bleus qui ne correspond à la
façade ouest donc la france est entre
les deux je crois qu'il appartient à
tout le monde de garder son sang-froid
de faire en sorte que le service public
d'éducation continue de fonctionner
autant que faire ce feu
je il faudrait être aussi plus nuancé
que ne l'est mon collègue m'a jama en
constatant que disent les enseignants ne
demande pas tous un protocole renforcé
beaucoup réclament de pouvoir enseigner
sans le masque et constate le faible
taux de létalité de la maladie pour
ressembler à s'y soustraire donc si vous
voulez il ya dans le monde enseignant
comme dans la population française des
gens qui pensent qu'on en fait trop
doute qu'il pense qu'on n'en font pas
donc on fait passer ce qui doit nous
rassembler c'est l'intérieur super du
pays
l'intérêt supérieur des élèves et le
syndicat national des écoles se fait
fort d'avoir une attitude équilibrée là
dedans
et pour l'instant de ce que nous
constatons sur le terrain il y a tout
lieu de penser qu'on doit pouvoir
continuer sereinement à accueillir tous
nos élèves en maintenant bien entendu
les gestes barrière autant que faire se
peut merci à tous les deux pierre fabre
benjamin a marre d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france